[Applause]
[Music]
all right we're back here on overtime on
the internet and we're being joined by
the doctor are you a real doctor Frank a
PhD from Oxford really Oxford
Mississippi I was okay so okay this is
one for you will Kane do you think
Americans have given terrorism at least
some power by letting fear of violence
dictate the extent to which our
government is willing to criticize oh
man this guy talks like Obama at a
debate criticized religious leadership
in the Middle East I couldn't follow it
either but what do you think about this
each question okay absolutely
well you're with me on this one yes
Christopher Hitchens once said that the
offensive speech is the most important
to protect if one guy stands up and he's
the heretic in the room and he goes
against every other consensus his
opinion becomes the most important I
fully believe that and when you're
speaking about religion the most do you
think this evening this Benghazi Cape
thing is anything I've heard you talk
about it on Fox for it's the one thing
that you and I agree with I think we
agree which is that there aren't equal
allies in the Middle East we have one
Ally and that Ally is Israel and we
should defend it and stand out further
that's true
but I mean I feel like the Republicans
many of them feel like what happened in
Benghazi was something that could have
been prevented or that somehow there
were the administration's response to it
is corrupt and I don't know where
they're getting that I mean yes they did
not know immediately what kind of an
attack it was they thought it might have
been a spontaneous uprising on 9/11 what
Dad and I'm not buying any of that right
there
what do you think we came 24 hours Eli
Lake today Lea Beach has been reporting
on this they knew that for terrorists it
is they knew were one of them was and
within a what a week later two weeks
later Susan Rice was still going out on
the sunday talk show circuit stank
saying was a spontaneous reaction to
that innocence of Muslims video they
were just propagating something that was
not true but that proves that what he's
a Obama's and Muslim Brotherhood is
asking
what I think I think it improved it
proves incompetence negligence and some
form of deception for covering up for
the negligence I guess you left out
later leading from behind so what is
this leading from behind that's that's
their big what does it say that they
that there's a group of people that riot
because of a stupid film now we're
talking about the attack now exactly
since why do we always have to be
responsible because they're [ __ ] nuts
okay but if the administration believes
again back to the earlier comment I made
if they believe that this little video
caused that uprising they should put a
halt to the Navy SEALs film that's about
to come up right because if you're
wanting to light up the Middle East let
him get on that show it'll always be
something it's always certain right it's
always something in daily right
interesting thing was that the people in
Benghazi then took care of this problem
in a certain way right fairly bravely
waiting that's what they that's what I
don't hear on Fox News that we made
Libya our friends they love us now we
got rid of the bad man and we made a
friend which we need around the world
yeah but you don't hear that on Fox News
because you don't watch Fox News yeah I
do sometimes watch Fox News right do you
ever see the group's I do of course
thank you
Frank what you think I know to refer to
you as evil
Frank what would you say here's a
question to the Republican voters who
believe that the polls are skewed in
favor of the Democrats now I heard this
a lot recently that they think the polls
are a liberal conspiracy stops stop
complaining about it
you're gonna have good polls you know
bad polls focus on the issues focus on
what's going on focus on what the
candidates are saying and if you're
gonna blame the polls then they're gonna
come back and blame you and what do you
think about this Rasmussen focus some
people say that this guy who was a
conservative pollster he somehow comes
out with polls that don't agree with any
of the other polls and have Romney ahead
that and yet the one who's and yet he
was the most accurate and I've heard the
criticism realized the most accurate in
2008 he had Barack Obama within less
than 1% of his actual total in 2000
always wonder where the pollsters get
their data Jay I was well I was down 14
points in the Florida race in 92 and I
won by I was down 12 and I won by 14 two
weeks out Wow
so if I read that poll and I would have
gone home and cried who why do you think
that was I just think sometimes they
call the same people polling data today
you know bubble phones
telecommunications different than I used
to be put 92 there weren't any cell
phones no I mean well they were they
were about this size yeah right line up
with a satellite but I mean I often
wonder about that same thing these
people who are answering the phones are
not indicative of the nation which is a
length
I remember Lester Manteno where
and again you're worried to who's what's
the purpose of the call what what are
they doing with the data to sometimes to
get them up yeah I support that guy
whoever it is you said and then once
they get you on the phone long enough
the push poll starts if you knew this
about right what would you do
pretty soon you've gone from this
popular guy to the piece of dirt and
it's all push polling but anyone who's
such a lonely cat hoarding loser that
they would talk to a poster for you talk
to me tonight what you talked to me
tonight what Frank stop Bill what would
what one action would make the most
immediate of immediate positive impacts
on our environment
oh I think I know carbon tax right a
direct carbon tax well if you're asking
I mean raising the making internalizing
the externalities as the economists say
making carbon pay the price for the
damage it does ending the kind of
ability of the greatest special break
any industry ever got the fossil fuel
industry allowed to pour its waste out
for free that would help but the only
way we're gonna get there if the
question is what's the thing that an
ordinary person could do that would help
the most the answer to that is organize
I mean if we don't build a movement like
to do this then it's not and a half
right recycling is not gonna mean
changing the lightbulb is nice but
changing this structure it's a citizen I
always say it's like saying we could
have won world war two by saving tin yes
did people say tin did it help yes but
it also helped that within one year FDR
said yeah yes it was no more cars made
everything made tanks and claims you
know in nineteen forty three and how
many cars were made in America one
hundred and thirty nine hundred thirty
nine thousand a hundred and thirty nine
cars and they were probably all four
generals you know but economics changes
this debate I mean I remember in Florida
and gas prices started rising I was
fighting offshore drilling as soon as
gases got to a certain point everybody
said no nevermind go ahead and row and
you'll find that today in California
$5.00 550 people lose their
sentimentality for the environment they
just want a whale so
I'm telling you the economics play a
role here where normal people who would
have heretofore said I'm with you
getting rid of their fossil fuels all of
a sudden said just kidding my Prius at
50 miles a gallon but what what is is
what I was trying to ask on the show
what has to happen where that scale tips
where I mean you called it
sentimentality I mean we have these
horrible droughts I mean people are the
UN reports had 400,000 people worldwide
now die every year because of global
warming I mean what happened you have to
have two heads
maybe maybe win the presidential
candidate he'd show up and I was gone
you know it doesn't exist
what's Mitt Romney's there in a hazmat
suits taking god Bless America
Temari think of our energy policy we
actually turn corn into fuel if that
isn't the stupidest thing it was stupid
it right romaine is supid and that's
because food kids we can't feed the poor
and hungry but we're sitting there and
that's where primary is in Iowa
absolutely and both candidates have to
pander to people who grow corn all right
thank you folks thank you panel you're a
great real-time you'd do more Friday
night a chair
ask bill and his guests to have
questions right after the show at
hbo.com